hello there
reject nation I'm Greg
I've learned that women can speak for
themselves so I'm not gonna introduce
you or is that is that rude of me not to
do that no I think you can say and this
is and this is a woman I'm doing very
well I'm so glad to be back on your
channel no that's some good acting
skills you got ten actors who turned
down iconic roles for stupid reasons is
what we're gonna watch today I'm trying
to think of who I would expect to be on
this look I'm expecting Will Smith from
the matrix I could be wrong
any here guys make sure to check out Amy
our Burns YouTube channel as soon as you
can it is a wonderful time one day I'll
be on there I'd say by the time this
videos out I might already be on there
might be on there yeah but we gotta do
something more like formal I think yes
okay I'm already happy how you talk to
real British people it's on the list but
it is brought up
in wolfman x-men the role was everyone's
favorite mutant the superhero who made
the cinematic x-men I think Wolverine
also wonderfully played by Hugh Jackman
for almost two decades across the x-men
franchise but a little before Jackman
took apart and even before debrief Scott
was set to play Wolverine but had to
back out due to scheduling conflicts
Russell Crowe was actually direct at
Bryan Singer's first choice hilariously
Crowe building one aspect of the
character was just to simulates in his
oscar-winning role as Maximus in Ridley
Scott's gladiator or well she finished
building a few months before x-men went
into production crew said in an
interview quote if you remember Maximus
has a wolf as his companion at the
beginning of the film which I thought
was gonna be a bigger deal at the time
so I said no no way apocalypse before
Jake Gyllenhaal won the star-making role
Kelly looked at numerous other actors
including Jason Schwartzman a 30-year
old Vince Vaughn and most baffling one
who are they
wahlbowlers at all you had sensibly
turned down the role because he
appreciated that he was too old to play
sixteen-year-old Donny but that
apparently wasn't a problem for Wahlberg
the actor was quite keen to take the
part though decided to walk away after
Kelly rejected his insistent idea for
the character that he played Donny with
a lisp it makes the brain hurt even
trying to conceive how anyone could
consider a 2000 era wahlberg
age-appropriate to play a high school
student that's not the bras she is not
she is so not attractive she didn't want
to play the girlfriend character yes
again and was disappointed that Vanessa
wasn't given any opportunities to be
physical throughout the film so far so
reasonable Fox was still interested in
Munn and offered her a role in another
x-men movie x-men apocalypse right
sitting at roughly the same time as
Deadpool that role was super mutant silo
which Munn contrasted with the role of
Vanessa by noting the added physicality
and the fact that she wasn't simply
being used as quotes by candy accept
anyone who's seen x-men apocalypse
probably won't remember much about
pretty much I can't change the role in
question for this one was
you can't come very close to casting
both the wires Michael K Williams and
Will Smith Williams ended up losing out
in the final stretch but Smith was
actually offered the parts in earnest
before turning it down
Smith is notoriously picky about his
projects in one very specific way he
doesn't do a lot of supporting ensemble
work and likes to develop products that
have focused around him as a star
vehicle and even when it came to an
awards without sound like this slide
turning the park down because he felt
like Django wasn't the true lead of the
film Smith said in an interview years
after Jagger's so it was like I thought
it was just for me atrocious and which I
like
as well as a I feel like that's rare
great then you get back then hated
wearing the mask leaf event death the
role was the titular anarchist terrorist
whose face is obscured under a mask the
debtor identifiable only by his voice
James wasn't only offered the role of B
he actually initially accepted it and go
as far as spending six months filming
before being replaced by Hugo Weaving
fascinated by weaving there are several
different perspectives on what exactly
went down though by far the most
persistently cited story is that he quit
the role due to discomfort over wearing
a mask for the entirety of the shoot in
an interview prior to leaving the film
the actor said quote that mask is the
thing I'll be wearing throughout the
movie will never see my face it's a
great acting challenge wearing that
thing takes a lot of takes we think
himself added later
quotes I know the difficulties James was
having and I was warned by other people
certain difficulties with the mask I
just think it can feel very hot we feel
quite cut off though James has himself
quaint creative differences was the
reason that seems to be an explanation
suggested only by himself well as crews
who ultimately said no crews wasn't keen
on the prospect of the first time
Darwin was busy trying to convince the
rule of sneek was first offered to Tim
Roth
yeah she would she would have been yes
actually after doing marry with children
by the terrific Christina Applegate
Applegate you just spent a decade dumb
blonde Kelly Bundy on the hit show
married with children who's worried that
taking such a role would result in her
being typecast in movies
right after I just finished married with
children and he was a blonde human that
birth scripts didn't win its but ends up
going to Yale or Harvard I don't
remember
I got scared of kind of repeating myself
down of course in tiny daughters over
the fact that he's gonna come back now
damn that looked a little like little
stingers they take at them
they turn this down for good reasons oh
well then they went on a star in this
business
yeah very particular British fashion
yeah like jam it's over before you this
is a good list I literally delivered all
these were pretty interesting to learn
about Russell Crowe with the wolf thing
with wolf you know it's just remind me
Hugh Jackman when he got the role of
Wolverine he didn't realize what ovaries
were their own animals he would do these
like weird preparations and murder and
talk time about interview these like
preparations watching wolves like
studying what's he like change this body
language and then on the day of filming
that are like what do you do that day
that Wolverines are a completely
different animal I slightly spotted one
at a zoo once but they didn't look at
all what I thought they would look like
I honestly thought they would look like
a wall yeah it is a common Association I
find Russell Crowe's reasoning to
turning this down a little funny
gladiator had a wolf I barely remember
anything about wolves I'm sure he was
seen it was like so close to the time of
the release at the same time I'm like
it's a completely different genre and
fell and I kind of feel like the
narrator of this video was like it was
stupid because there were so many like
the Wolverine role was many movies and
the gladiator was critically acclaimed
but one well I mean actually yeah they
are iconic roles as they all went to the
best actor totally I don't think
gladiator hurt Mark Wahlberg for Donny
dark even though if I'm funny about this
Mark Wahlberg have you heard of The
Lovely Bones Ryan Gosling was originally
cast in it really and then in the middle
of pre-production Ryan Gosling put on a
shits on a wait because that's what he's
envisioned for the character to be
really overweight Peter Jackson was like
why you fat get out of here
Oh whatever New Zealand accent yes why
are you fat yeah it fit boy now yeah
you're I am i sighs I could like Peter
Jackson if not exactly like a New
Zealanders
right there mark walberg eventually took
over for lovely bones following the way
the director vision did yeah but
apparently back then he could have had
this other iconic role but he wanted a
list yeah why is that necessary look I
don't want playing a nineteen-year-old
but I gotta have a list for I would love
to hear what the I like the real like
character her work it was like here's
why here's sometimes people are so
married to a certain choice they just
can't let it go
actors and their egos and I write
totally our selves Olivia Munn doesn't
want to be eye candy but she'll put on
but she'll be I can't marry I mean that
thing I'm pretty sure she had I high
boots on yes she looked amazing oh yeah
well I think a lot of the time for these
bigger roles sometimes I don't think
they're allowed to read the whole script
the character of Vanessa and Deadpool is
a pretty rich character it's like yeah
there's the whole like sex montage they
have but she's more than just girlfriend
like she I think that one thing that
people were kind of surprised by was
that she's actually a full
three-dimensional character and such an
integral part to the journey of Deadpool
in this one movie she's not just she
gave a great performance in that film
because it's a good character a lot of
times - I think that when actresses
especially are cast in these like
superhero films I don't think that are
aware of the outfits they're gonna be
told they have to wear and it's also you
don't have that much power at the time
so usually you have to be compliant with
whatever the requests are I can see a
scenario where she hurries you should
probably didn't get the whole Deadpool
story agreed to be this comic book
character and then being in the position
of oh I have to dress like that I'm not
much of a character later on you find
out you know they mentioned that - right
that she doesn't actually have that big
of a role in the know the superhero
roles I forget she's in it you know Amy
turned down the role of Tanya and I
Tanya you don't because quote I didn't
want success Will Smith for Django I
totally believed that I mean
is one of the most charming mother
effers in the world and I love him and I
love his motivational talks and
everything but I also can believe he if
you wanted to be more of the center of
attention
I know a little upsetting to learn this
actually because I don't think some
actors who have really large egos I
think you're like oh yeah but I don't
think Will Smith carries himself that
way but this is very big ego this is
yeah I'm not the star I've heard he
overall doesn't even agree with the
choices about some of the story things
like I heard talk in an interview I
think I'm like one of those Hollywood
round tables sort of themes that he
didn't agree with I think it kind of has
a point
it is Django's movie still title role
yeah he's a title role and he is the one
with the crazy arc and it does end off
with him being the hero of the tale but
I think most people still walk away
thinking about DiCaprio or cursed off
waltz terms of like the big performances
because like the Django performance is
very subtle and the other performances
have a lot more dialogue it's tough you
know hey you know what respect to mr.
Smith yeah Gemini man yeah okay no heart
and they were great in pursuit of
happiness Sean Connery turning down four
hundred million dollars
Will Smith was originally be the one
they're recording for the matrix I
couldn't really see that happening and
then Sean Connery there originally
according for Morpheus I can't really
see that either no I think he could have
done it but it would have been a
completely different vibe cuz I think
one of the cool things about the matrix
is you walk away with all the characters
the main players at least whereas I
think if you got Sean Connery as
Morpheus you would mainly think of Sean
Connery and would he do the training for
the fighting and stuff what do you
really have done all that Connery this
was before the big stunt days yeah we're
actors actually trained in series to
learn martial arts for six months but it
would've been a good Gandalf yeah yeah I
surprisingly can very much see him as
Gandalf
your knee has like the white hair and
the beer gun like yeah you're gonna
could have died knees you'd be like a
bombastic or like really loud kind of
performance and deliver these epic
speeches he would have been cool
he would have would he have been
Scottish though or do you think he would
have he would have a hundred percent
Scottish even when I watched Bond movies
with him I'm like I could hear this girl
I think you would have very happy he
would have tried you wouldn't have
succeeded it would have been a really
funny twist yeah Scotland they may take
our lives but they'll never take our
freedom
yeah we'll what you're our Butler does
bother you through his mouth there Your
Honor I am an American see this James
Purefoy not taking on the V for Vendetta
mask because it was hot I see the thing
is everyone on this list I know but I'm
like I know who James Purefoy and that's
on me it wasn't but I didn't really go
into detail Hugo Weaving was kind of
talking about how it could be
uncomfortable but I'm like are you
getting paid like a [ __ ] ton of money to
star in this great film yeah like really
well with Natalie Portman I would endure
it it's like I've endured way worse
dating you know it's definitely
something you can bring out in the press
circuit you know I probably how the mask
was so hot and I suffered for my art you
know that's true and nothing actors like
hope and more than suffering and being
credited for it yeah
I know look at me poor me what a great
performance very good very good yeah I
mean I understand that the challenges
that would come with wearing a mask but
sounds like the other actor who took the
role embraced them Tom Cruise turning
down a Shawshank Redemption because the
first time director I mean that makes a
guy get it but Wow
in retrospect yeah he would have been
way better than Tim Roth nor Tim Robbins
no trust me I know you know I know I've
seen sporadic random clips of Shawshank
Redemption still don't know how it ends
Wow well I'm not gonna spoil anything
for you because that would be rude they
end up together in the end are they they
become lovers that doesn't happen
No Wow spoilers I guess when the credits
are rolling
oh yeah no Tim Robbins and Morgan
Freeman had a huge huge doing it that's
an extended edition no it extended over
raaah turning down its Snape I'm glad he
did I think Tim Roth is a great actor
but man Alan Rickman is probably perfect
the way how great he is in that movie
you're just like he must have been the
first choice right I read the first
three Harry Potter books and I'm and I
just it's impossible for me to like not
imagine Alan Rickman it's it's
impossible he's likely all of the actors
in that movie you're seeing Applegate as
much as I agree with what they're saying
of how the movie is subverting
expectations and you're watching a dumb
blonde character evolve into someone
who's like actually a lot smarter than
she realized she is it's a lot more
authority in her life that are Kaito
agrees all present in the film a big
part of my legal aid bond great I still
think though that because she was on
married with children for ten years she
still would have been primarily
associated with you know playing dumb
blonde character a lot even if she did
do Legally Blonde that's the one choice
I'm like I don't think that was a stupid
choice I think that's actually really
smart of her and it makes sense there's
a big movie but still yeah I mean that's
the thing about it's like she is that
bubbly ah person even in her really
great strong intellectual moments
exactly but that's still like the
essence
Ellis probably happy blonde ridges with
both things you can be insane timer and
a bubble evil yeah shocking I don't know
if that's entirely true let me explain
explain Ralph Macchio turning down back
to the future
ouch
I'm glad Michael J Fox got the role
because Ralph Macchio as much as I love
Ralph I like love Ralph Macchio Michael
J Fox is too perfect for this to perfect
alright guys well any people on this
list that you think should have been on
here anyone that you think it would have
been better if they went with the
original picks how about that
Oh engagement questions for you too yeah
oh my god what is going on up here
written subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell checkout
Amy our Burns YouTube channel we talked
for so and I'd like to end this with a
patron of the day shout out to a woman
named Katie Ann is from the East Coast
and she started up her own movie review
blog site wonderful writer she is so
great at forming her opinions and such
an efficient eloquent matter I don't I
couldn't even say that properly cuz I
was so self-conscious comparing my
reviews to hers yeah she's hyper
intelligent super creative writes great
poetry she's also a beautiful woman -
what do you know you can be beautiful
and have a brain Wow I mean I knew that
about me yeah but the other genders yeah
ladies - you got you got some time to go
yes we're smart yes we're cute get over
it
don't talk to my man base like that it's
alright most people don't make it to the
end that's just for you Katie
you guys should collab sometime yeah I
want to collab with all kinds of people
check my stuff oh I'll check you out
it'll be great
all right thanks Katie